[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
sallys wendt ich habe jetzt meinen
youtube kanal schon seit sieben jahren
habe auch auf dieser plattform gestartet
und youtube hat schon maßgeblich mein
leben verändert vorher war ich studentin
dann lehrerin habe eine familie
gegründet mittlerweile bin ich nicht
mehr direkt nach dem wobei ich ja welche
videos mache aber mein hauptjob ist
jetzt mein youtube kanal und das
unternehmen dahinter in den letzten
wochen hat man ja viel über youtube
gesprochen viel spekuliert viel
diskutiert aber es hat noch keiner mit
youtube gesprochen
also habe ich jetzt andreas briese
eingeladen er ist youtube director in
deutschland und zentraleuropa und er hat
die einladung angenommen wird heute hier
mit mir buttons und ich werde ihnen
heute mit fragen löchern
zum beispiel montag
ich weiß du bist der endgegner der
youtube-chef daraus tragen aber alle
hausschuhe haben dass ich habe bleibe ja
ich habe nur noch punkte weiß nicht was
ich zu hause trage von bayer ist es
wahrscheinlich weniger schlimm als du
denkst klares 8 da waren ja noch graue
der mich gar nicht gesehen
ja das ist die küche die kennst du ja
schon aus dem video
ich bin beeindruckt ist ungefähr so groß
wie meine wohnung ja ich mag ja
wahrscheinlich ob es mehr als
wahrscheinlich
aber wir sind schon ein partner noch ich
habe extra tief ist leider schon
gefühlte nummer eins gefunden ich glaube
das hängt bis zehn jahre hat sollte sich
hier auf einen kleinen können
aber ich habe mir gedacht ich hätte ich
nicht nur mit fragen sondern wir backen
auch gleichzeitig was du hast du ja das
hab ich doch ich habe ein einfaches
rezept weil ich nicht so genau weiß wie
ba cav jeden du bist wie viel erfahrung
ich bin sehr backmischung verfahren
dann machen wir eben eine eigene wohnung
aber bevor wir hier starten müssen wir
leider kurz in die werkstatt wir backen
heute nämlich einen ein brot und wir
bauen unsere backform selber jetzt wird
es interessant also jetzt geh mal kurz
in ihre werkstatt waren die backform
zusammen
und dann packen wir hier unser brot da
los ich hoffe du liebst
ich esse ja ich meine wenn man ein
frisches brot ist die werkstatt
fantastisch so dass er rot form genau
das ist die brot form das ist echt ganz
einfach die kamera im prinzip auch so
kaufen aber es ist natürlich viel viel
cola die selbst zu machen und wichtig
ist nur dass man ahornholz nimmt weil
man wolle sich bei
temperaturunterschieden und bei
feuchtigkeit nicht ausgeht dass erhält
die form wir wollen ja immer noch schöne
backform haben schneiden weil es so
einfach zu ich habe hier das holz
bereits vorbereitet das ist ziel ja dort
genau also wenn's schief geht habe ich
schon mal hatten sie noch fragen also
back erfahrungen so aber handwerk
handwerklich also im hammer umlage habe
ich schon mal dabei
und simon alle finger okay das kriegen
wir hin mit denen aus und schneiden
jetzt das holz zurecht und mit sehr gut
ich würde mir dort eine bürgerin
[Musik]
hat sich hier schneiden war hab' schon
mal mit der geschnitten mit dem modell
noch nicht aber ich war schon über
casino.com alles vorbereitet und zwar
habe ich den anschlag
damit wir ich habe alles schon
abgesessen und jetzt schneiden wir das
einmal zu 2 lange 2 kurze was mache ich
darf sagen wenn dieses schreiben also
ich riskiere jetzt meine finger also
haben wir erst mal so ein anschlag damit
es schön glatt ist das play ist schön
glatt ist immer ein guter tipp und
dadurch mehr anlegen ja und wie lange
ist schneiden
[Applaus]
1 von mehrheits von dem jetzt möchte ich
auf jeden fall unsere bugfrei einer tür
nicht so also erst die kurze seite so
dass tricky wegen wegen finger gefahren
wenn wir das jetzt hier und jetzt hier
den finger wickeln und hier oben
kurzzeitig sah so finger weg
was mir jetzt hier an der scharfen kreis
wege einfällt artikel 13 wie wir den
artikel 13 auf deutschland zugeschnitten
ist schon ziemlich heikles thema gewesen
die letzten woche interessante orte mich
zu fragen der 13
auf deutschland zugeschnitten wird an
der kreisschau dass manche spieler nicht
eingegangen sein
gute frage ich habe zunächst muss man
sagen dass die version die am endeffekt
als europäische urheberrecht richtlinie
verabschiedet wurde
gegenüber derjenigen die ursprünglich
mal auf dem tisch lag und diskutiert
wurde klare verbesserung und das ist
schon mal das ist wirklich die gute
nachricht wir bleiben aber trotzdem
besorgt über gegebenenfalls
unabsichtliche unabsichtliche
konsequenzen dieser richtigen die zur
folge haben können dass es schon
deutliche nachteile mit sich bringen für
naja die kreativen die auf youtube
unterwegs sind und insgesamt für
digitalwirtschaft von dem was jetzt
passiert ist in den nächsten zwei jahren
dass die eu richtlinie in lokale das
gesetz umgewandelt wird
das sind prozesse
interpretationsspielraum gibt und dass
ein prozess wirklich wo es war wirklich
auch die details ankommt also da sitzt
das es jetzt eigentlich die
entscheidende phase wie jetzt für andere
steht das was die faktor ist der fall
ist und es ist eine gute sache ist dass
das plattform wenn sie sich mit den
rechteinhabern zusammen um die
identifikation und den schutz von
rechten kümmern
das liege nicht für jedes video haftbar
gemacht werden können oder neuen
richtigen was kommt geladen wird das ist
schon immer das ist schon mal gut sagt
extrem schwierig dass die kontrollierte
ich meine da hätte der alles und
streicht von bruder stunde pro minute
ist das keine einfache aufgabe aber
nichtsdestotrotz machen wir uns gedanken
sind weiterhin besorgt über verschiedene
dinge zum einen enthält die richtlinie
diverse auflagen wie vage formuliert
sind in unna probt sind und die dazu
führen können aufgrund der
rechtsunsicherheit dass mehr inhalte
geblockt werden als das wahrscheinlich
sein müsste ein thema es herrscht
unsicherheit darüber was mit inhalten
geschieht beziehungsweise auf plattform
haftbar sind für videos die hochgeladen
werden wo die rechte informationen
einfach nicht klar hinterlegt sind
unvollständig sind oder umstritten sind
ja und wo war außerdem unsicherheit
herrscht ist in welcher art und weise
die rechteinhaber mitwirken müssen um
rechte zu schützen aus unserer sicht ist
das extrem wichtig wir haben viel
technologie im einsatz
aber die funktioniert erst dann wenn wir
informationen bekommen von den
rechteinhabern das sind präferenz files
unser content die matching ganz
funktioniert das sind die dazugehörigen
metadaten die dann hat mit zuordnung
erlauben zwischen rechteinhaber und
inhalt und das ist wichtig ja aber so
ein thema das anspricht was eine menge
leute bewegt hat sich ja auch noch vier
videos online viele menschen die mit
diskutiert haben aber es gab ja auch
viele muss ich sagen die es gab viele
die darüber bescheid wusste und viele
gut bis gut mit diskutiert haben aber
auch viele die einfach zum beispiel auf
ein axel voss richtig eingeschlagen
haben verbal fand ich schon extrem kraft
was muss man tun irgendwo muss ja die
rechteinhaber schützen und dialog hat er
auch ja was was gut ist was sehr gut ist
ich finde bei jeder diskussion muss
immerhin auch wenn sie kontrovers
geführt muss ein element von fairness
dabei sein das ist schon richtig
ich persönlich war extrem beeindruckt
über gibt wie viel das thema leute
bewegt hat die compass münchen von da
ich kann mich noch erinnern als die
demonstration in münchen waren aber und
40.000 leute auf der straße zwar nicht
überwältigend
ich habe die relativ vielen leuten
gesprochen was mich beeindruckt wie gut
die informiert die alle beamten also
dass man definitiv keine box sondern
sehr gut informierte menschen die sich
auch eine sehr valide meinung zu dem
thema gebildet haben für uns heißt das
ja ja und man darf eines nicht vergessen
wir nehmen urheberrechte ernst wir
verstehen auch ein stehen auch hinter
den absichten der europäischen
urheberrechts direktive worum es
wirklich darauf ankommt ist die
umsetzung das jetzt detail arbeit und da
kann ich ehrlich gesagt auch nur an
diejenigen die das will mit behaftet
sind appellieren zu appellieren dass er
das im hintergrund haben und im
hinterkopf haben was was um was es
eigentlich geht
weil eigentlich es geht zum einen die
plattform es geht zum anderen um das was
durch youtube entstanden ist nämlich ein
riesiges ökosystem an kreativen wie dich
und viele andere sind viele
hunderttausende in deutschland die mit
der plattform zusammenarbeiten das ist
ein standes einzigartig und das gilt es
zu bewahren und das sollte man nicht
vergessen wir helfen aber natürlich
kenne ich
ist das ist sehr schön die zwei haben
wir schon perfekt es wäre doch die zwei
kurzen teile dann ist unser baukasten
gleich fertig jetzt wird es ein bisschen
gefährlich denn ich habe jetzt ein
anschlag dahinten ich kann ihnen gern
nach vorne bohren oder wir nehmen
einfach hier die linie die eigene zeit
das schaffen wir
[Musik]
wir können auch in die produktion
starten wir können ja schauen was
kleiner was das ist der rest genommen
auf gehts euch verlassen heisst ja ich
weiß wir können ja später weiter
das filmmärchen erstmal das proton wenn
es dir dann geht es dann okay jetzt habe
ich hier die form und wir kämpfen und
ich hier einfach die bohrlöcher dem
zollstock großen eigene zollstock
ich brauchte ihn so oft kommen dann
einfach einen zentimeter und hier oben
drängen kann soll ich das jetzt machen
ja auf alle viel viel schlimmer da also
immer in der ecke
aha hier versteht es kapiert da muss man
jetzt mal richtig verstanden habe dann
also hier oder hier in der werkstatt aus
dass es auch weg statt videos kennst du
noch ein mal wer da hämmert könnt euch
die serie früher ja und das machen wir
hier
morath und gummi und sally morath macht
alles kaputt nur einmal
alexion machen alles richtig so und dann
haben wir jetzt hier
damit die bohrlöcher richtig schön
gerade werden
das schönschreiben despoten zu bleiben
[Musik]
aber ebenso von hör mal wer da hämmert
gesprochen ja das muss sich erst finden
das ist ja so alte ferien und auch viele
neue serien auch netflix amazon prime
und so weiter und meinst du ist wieder
auf youtube irgendwann auch mal so einen
streaming-dienst geben kostenpflichtig
und kostenpflichtigen diensten und
menschlich sie machen ja youtube ist
schon anders darf nicht vergessen wir
sind kein geschlossenes system sondern
youtube ist eine offene plattform das
heißt der plattform wo jeder inhalte
hochladen die wahrscheinlich größte
bühne der welt und von daher ist unser
modell an dass wir versuchen definitiv
nicht sozusagen wie amazon und netflix
sagen wir versuchen eine plattform zu
bieten denn stimme hat und inhalte
produzieren will wenn du große serie
produziertes bisschen natürlich herzlich
eingeladen das auch youtube zu tun
aber du kannst du auch kleine videos
machen von daher sind wir dort sehr
offen was da auf der plattform ist
nichtsdestotrotz wir haben natürlich in
der region das projekt aber der große
unterschied ist dass das ein projekt ist
wo wir auch neulich gesagt haben was wir
allen zur verfügung stellen wollen das
ist etwas was wir hinter der pace
ursprünglich mal war hervorhoben wollen
muss wohl die payroll zu stellen
bei uns geht es immer darum möglichst
viel inhalte möglichst allen nutzern zur
verfügung zu stellen
das geschäftsmodell ist verteilt ein
werbefinanziertes modell als ein modell
also für nutzer eigentlich völlig
kostenfrei viele nutzer kostenfrei für
den create oder spannende möglichkeiten
sich weiterzuentwickeln das darf man
aber nicht vergessen unser ansatz auch
bei den youtube originals war immer mit
creator zusammenzuarbeiten krise war
immerhin das focus in den fokus der
produktion zu stellen was natürlich
teure für greater weil es eine
möglichkeit bietet einfach auf die
nächsten qualitätslevel zu kommen
spannende sachen zu machen dann eines
tages hat ganz wichtig creator und
künstler sind das herzstück der
plattform und die erzeugen aber auch die
größte resonanz weil wir einfach ein
riesen fan base haben auf youtube ist es
unsere absicht creator zu helfen
tolle produktionen zu machen die bei den
fans ankommen und gleichzeitig aus
unserer sicht nutzern spannende inhalte
zu bieten auch in der wahnsinnig tollen
qualität die die plattform interessant
sehr cool ich freue mich ich glaube wir
können uns alle darüber freuen was in
zukunft noch kommen wird
ich hoffe super-g zusammengestellt und
wir offizieren das jetzt mal irgendwo
watch er kurz festhalten am besten
helfen ja ja ich höre hier oben das ist
jetzt bündig am wichtigsten ist das ist
vorne auf einer seite bündig es nicht
dass der bug rahmen sozusagen auflegen
kann der ofen ist nicht so schlimm
also hier für sich haben halten ziemlich
individuell ist nicht normal was locker
mal so die erste schreck jetzt gucken
dass bei uns hier bin ich jetzt kehrt
sie zurück
so jetzt so und dann einfach nur noch
festschrauben
dann verschenken sie so ein bisschen
damals nichts passiert das war's im
prinzip schon
jetzt war ich schon mal hier ist dass
der käse oder ist nicht ganz ideal von
es ist bündig aber einerseits ist es
nicht ganz zufällig schlimm dass ein
millimeter zu kurz aber das passt in
brot gleicht aus
[Musik]
fertig eine backform gebaut war sind
jetzt wird gebacken jetzt sie wird
gebacken mir hat man tatsächlich auch in
banker teilnehmer benutzt also sollen
die vereine haben sie noch her
der vorteil ist einfach dass das brot
darin etwas länger weil sie ja bisher
isoliert und dann backt ist natürlich
höher und der kampf wird schöne weichen
oben und unten also die kruste ja sagt
das wäre ziemlich ziemlich lecker
ich bin gesprächsbereit wie immer
perfekt wir müssen jetzt die bank
vorerst noch ein fed nun ein brennen
auch vorher abruzzen noch direkt aus der
werkstatt
ok also die einmal gewöhnt vom holz
staub befreien
ich bemühe mich echt meist hochdeutsch
zu sprechen ich meine normalerweise
später ist wirklich viel dialekt
aber das problem ist ich habe ja auch
viele die zu schauen aus anderen ländern
also auch viel aus griechenland aus
polen und ich verstehe natürlich kein
deutsch und mussten an diesem google
übersetzer dem translator und der
versteht kein badisch wirklich mit
bleiben und dann probiere ich echt immer
hochdeutsch zu sprechen
gibt's da also ich meine da muss jetzt
kein badisch verstehen aber auch wenn
ich mich bemühe hochdeutsch zu sprechen
klappt nicht immer da kommt immer so
ziemlich viel unsinn raus gibt's da
irgendwie mal eine verbesserung oder ich
mein technisches technologisch bestimmt
ziemlich aufwendig auch zwei aber was
ich glaube barbisch ist besonders
technologisch auf wird nicht von daher
kann ich nicht garantieren dass es die
im schwäbischen noch schlimmer bei mir
funktioniert ganz gut aber
nichtsdestotrotz ich werde das feedback
das projekt ihm auf jeden fall weiter ja
aber ich vermute mal was du eigentlich
mainz ist produziert in deutsch immer
und dann was war interesse am herzen das
publikum zu erreichen und wie machst du
das am besten
und ich habe auch viele muss ich sagen
die auch gehörlos sind ja und auch immer
sagen mach doch untertitel weiter
klar könnte ich machen es bei uns
inzwischen mega aufwand noch rein zu
schreiben und wenn man dann sich das
deutsch mal durchliest dann denke ich so
'oh mein gott zu sprechen und da draußen
ein sondern sein also um internationales
publikum zu erreichen
das ist auf jeden fall ein interessantes
thema was ihr viele machen weil wir sind
die gruppe unplugged von menschen geht
dort in england zu erreichen was in
frankreich zu erreichen
auch wenn ich aber extrem erfolgreich
ist wenn du tatsächlich in
zweisprachigen kanal probierst ist auf
englisch oder französisch produzieren
sondern ganz lustig sein kann
aber das hat auch wenn ich die 22 jahre
als erster so wirklich eigene untertitel
schreibst das ist sicherlich gerade über
kochrezepte tolle idee oder die leute
nur mitlesen können verstehe aber dass
auch ein bisschen aufwendig ist es gibt
eine funktion wurde über die fanbase auf
youtube untertitel generieren kannst
also war das kennst fans schicken
untertitel ein das gegenüber setzen
selber du kannst du ein review und und
es anschließend schauten crowdsourcing
von untertiteln ist es echt und
untertitel sind gut weil wir haben
festgestellt die videos die untertitel
haben glaube ich performance so um die
15 prozent besser als die männer
unterschiedlich wir haben das
internationale publikum
dadurch war das ganz wichtig ja du bist
dann kannst du ja ich habe da
sonnenblumenöl umgelegt und so papier
küchenpapier
aber jetzt kann es einfach alle seiten
damit einstreichen und das brauchen wir
ja damit das holz eingebrannt wird dass
es eine glattere oberfläche bekommt und
während der teig aufgeht kann das in den
backofen bloß auf tour und dann auf
trainer ich habe hier schon mal die hefe
da kommen sie jetzt wasser dazu ist
immer so wenn ich das vorher mache dann
weiß ist das also
aber weißt du was zucker ist das hier
das ist noch mal links zu recht als das
ist ganz mehr
es wäre auch ziemlich cool wenn ich
meine videos synchronisieren könnte und
wann ich habe nicht nur englisch ich
habe auch noch türkisch und russisch
finde ich ziemlich cool so nah tischen
länder chinesisch wenn man dann so diese
synchronisierten videos in dies ist eine
video einbetten könnte und ja ein tolles
feature
teilweise sind jetzt überraschung gut
das bessere konzept
er wies auf das übrigens ein brot rezept
was man nicht mehr lange aufgehen lassen
muss gibt ja wirklich experten die
lassen das brot den teig 48 stunden
aufgeben je weniger hefe man nimmt umso
bekömmlicher wird das brot umso länger
muss man es aber auch aufgehen lassen
und ich muss echt sagen im alltag habe
ich dafür keine zeit also mit zwei kids
und murat drei kinder sozusagen das auch
philips oder moritz monat
die kinder hören irgendwann morath
leider nicht beim dritten mal spätestens
wenn die kleinen aber der moderne muss
immer wieder sagen
auch das feedback gebe ich gerne weiter
so und das ist echt ein cooles ford
rezept was man abends schnell machen
also einfach alle zutaten in den topf
und verkneten und ihr leben dazu fertig
die super aus wir können eigentlich
schon mal die backform reinstellen
in den barocken einfach weiß dass gerade
dies wäre eine stunde ein brennen lassen
es kann passieren dass ein bisschen
rauchentwicklung kommt aber deswegen
haben wir sonnenblumenöl das kann man
gut hoch erhitzen und dann lassen wir
den teig auf gehen und machen weiter so
eine stunde
aber bei dir in der schublade da hier da
ist sagt renn spray das ist mit dem
blauen deckel back transport die
arbeitsplatte das heißt das dass das ein
streich dazu jetzt machen ja einfach mal
ein bisschen mehr zusammenkneifen und
dann der kugel formen zusammen mit dem
spray von meine hände oder so da schon
getrennt sich alles viel besser meine
kids sind ja auch total gerne auf
youtube unterwegs
ich muss aber immer auch ein bisschen
natürlich mit kontrollieren also so ganz
ohne kontrolle mag ich dir nicht ans
handy lassen weil ich auch immer sehen
will was gucken sie denn da und wir bei
meinem zuschauer und sage ich immer
meine videos könnt ihr von den kids
gucken lassen da kommt nie was schlecht
ist irgendwas schlimmes denn vor
aber es gibt ja echt auch videos die
finde ich jetzt nicht auf youtube
gehören also ich erinnere mich an
unseren urlaub letztes jahr zurück da
hatte die lg konnte nachts nicht
schlafen und dann echt alles probiert
aber irgendwas war mit ihr sie wollte
einfach nicht schlafen und ich hab
gesagt komm wir gucken uns das auf
youtube und haben was eingeschaltet und
sie hatte immer gesagt angst und ich
wusste aber nicht woher und da war die
videos angeklickt und die klickt sich
dazu durch und kam plötzlich auf videos
wo irgendwie asiaten ich meine es hat
jetzt nichts mit der nationalität zu
treffen indem wir jetzt asiaten er
ständig eine große plastik spinne
irgendwo platziert haben die kinder
erschreckt haben und das video war aber
betitelt mit keine ahnung play doh
spielfiguren basteln oder man gestalten
und das ist ja schon so möchte man denkt
okay manchmal inhalte man wie
kontrolliert er das also wie kann man
solche inhalte ist schon extrem
schwierig weil viele videos hochgeladen
werden unter anderem titeln wie wie
macht ihr das als plattform ja das ist
ein wichtiges thema das ist
wahrscheinlich sogar das wichtigste
thema
sein dass zwei kinder drei kinder schon
mal betrifft es mich betrifft mich
genauso wie sich betrifft plattform
sicherheit qualität der inhalte ist das
entscheidende thema auseinandersetzen
und wir haben keine toleranz gegenüber
inhalten die nicht auf der plattform zu
finden sein sollten dass wo das
regelwerk praktisch nachdem wir unsere
plattform policen sind die community
guidelines wie es die nicht den
community teilweise entsprechend
entfernen wir dann werden wir auch
ziemlich rigoros ziemlich brust
das ist ein großes team das ist auch
eine kunst bei uns von 500 stunden pro
minute hochgeladen oder von jahres eine
aufgabe die wir gerade zwei ansätze
erledigen zum einen haben wir menschen
die videos geflickt werden sich diese
videos ansehen menschen haben den
vorteil dass sie den kontext besser
verstehen dass sie man sich besser
verstehen dass sie auch intentionen
besser verstehen und zum anderen haben
wir auch maschinen versuchen hat signal
aus dem video so dass kein titel sein
was man will informationen seien die den
flecken und dann von menschen reviewed
werden ansonsten kriegen die diese
skalierbarkeit nicht hin
das funktioniert muss man fairerweise
sagen haben auch viel gelernt in letzter
zeit eine offene plattform mit einer
sicheren plattform in der skalierbaren
art und weise zu kombinieren das ist
eigentlich die gegen wesentliche
schwierige aufgabe wir haben da
allerdings sehr gute fortschritte
gemacht im letzten ich glaube im quartal
4 2018 haben wir fast neun millionen
videos entfernt war richtig viel
70 prozent davon bevor sie irgendjemand
überhaupt gesehen
wir haben über zwei millionen kanäle
auch geschlossen also werden wir
verstöße gegen unsere kritiker eines
feststellen wenn videos entfernen bei
mehrfachen verstößen sperren wir videos
sperren wir auch ganze kanäle sondern
das thema wichtig wenn du kinder hast
dann muss man fairerweise sagen
youtube ist nicht unbedingt eine
plattform der ist kein klappern die für
kleinkinder geeignet ist
wir haben dann eigene app des youtube
ketchup die ist geeignet die safe da
hast du genug kontrollmöglichkeiten man
als elternteil da gibt's fantastisch die
kinder früh kochen lernen sie ja gut so
und da hast du das eltern
das war's elternteilen möglichkeiten
einfach einzustellen und modi zu wählen
wo du die video selber folge prüft hast
oder mit videos zu schauen die von vom
dritten vorher geprüft worden und
kuratiert worden sind
das ist eigentlich die die app der wahl
für kinder die nutzer können ja im
prinzip immer mitmachen wenn man kann ja
wirklich videos die nicht den richtigen
entsprechenden vermelden und ihr
kontrolliert ist und genau das ist
richtig wir haben prinzipiell besuchen
ist die größte polizei der welt nämlich
jemand nutzer ist ein ist ein polizist
aber bei schwierigen inhalten ist es
wichtig dass du halt ganz schnell
reagiert ja und da ist es hat
tatsächlich kombination aus nutzer das
wirklich algorithmen die wir einsetzen
und sehr sehr vielen menschlichen review
an die sich videos ansehen wenn sie den
gefleckt worden sind ja auch auf youtube
selber auf der messe wird es so dass
wenn du selber auch als nutzer tätig
sein willst musst du über 16 jahre alt
sein und ist es keine plattform für
kinder
du kannst über die family link funktion
das heißt unter begleitung von eltern
darf sich schon mit 16 auch in tieferen
auf der platte mit 13 tschuldigung aktiv
waren auf der plattform alle gesagt
youtube geht's wirklich meine die
pfälzer müssen eben immer schauen wir
lassen es ja auch nicht alleine macht
hört man ja auch so nicht nur okay wir
fahren jetzt das zu einer kugel den teig
decken den anlasser aufgehen
das haben jetzt eine kurze pause ist
immer gut
ich übernehme gerne deinem schönen
dampf backofen geht es übrigens
schneller ersparen wir uns zwei stunden
also unser tag ist super aufgegangen
die backform sieht es übrigens so aus
als stehe sie wieder
wichtig ist dass man die nie wäscht als
er nicht in wasser nicht in der
unterwäsche maschine einfach immer nur
die reste zum beispiel mit so einer
tankkarte abkratzen ja fürsten und dann
kann man nicht immer wieder so weiter
benutzen so die kommen jetzt noch mal
fetten also mit dem spray den tag genau
das habe ich mir auf einmal beim thema
sicherheit stehen und was ich mich
darauf
es gibt ja viele plattformen die bereits
so was wie fake accounts oder in der
identitätsdiebstahl auch verhindern
wie macht ihr das also ja schon
eigentlich ziemlich einfach sich account
zu machen und auch anzulegen und da
passiert es auf youtube erster überhaupt
kein interesse am diebstahl von
identitäten oder kamel
wir gehen aber rigoros ging vor das
bleibt das gleiche gilt gegen reich
bringen achim nicht aus
den teig den formt man dann gar nicht
viel machen dann macht man einfach so
eine lange rolle und immer schön von
außen nach innen damit in der
oberflächenspannung entsteht
auswirkungen richtig schön so der
sprecher weiter
also wir haben ihn wir haben da eine
null toleranz politik gegenüber nutzern
die versuchen andere identitäten zu
stehen als kanäle es hat sich als marken
vorgeben
wir gehen doch rigoros gegen vor wenn
wir videos finden die das tun entfernt
die förderplattform entsprechen nicht
unseren community guidelines der abholer
bekommt dann eine verwarnung
passiert das mehrere male dann kriegt
jetzt 3,3 streiks
entfernen wir die kamera von der
plattform ja wir arbeiten noch weiter an
methoden um das auch frühzeitig zu
detektieren und was wir auch auf youtube
haben sind ist ein kennzeichen von
verifizierten kanäle
wenn du ein kanal betreiber bis mit über
100.000 abonnenten kannst du dann kann
man einen reichen verifizieren lassen
er wird dann auch ihr kennzeichnen dass
hilfen nutzen tatsächlich zu
unterscheiden zwischen dem original
gleich eine kopie aber auf jeden fall
ist das eine wertvolle orientierung
oftmals sind sie wirklich zuschauer oder
fans die dann im kanal kopieren oder
bilder videos noch mal hoch laden ja was
ja auch sicherlich gut gemeint ist das
nicht unbedingt jetzt eine fälschung
oder jemand versucht sich anders
auszugeben aber es ist zumindest eine
orientierung zu nutzer für die nutzer zu
unterscheiden ist jetzt die echte city
und jetzt 110 und auf jeden fall ist es
jemand der sich ganz anders aus gibt
live brot mit decken es noch mal ab und
lassen es nur eine halbe stunde auf
gehen und dann backofen ansonsten der
stunde noch einmal aufgehen lassen und
es wird wirklich noch mal schön groß und
dann packen wir damit die wagen
da oben den ofen an
so ist nicht cool weil dann einfach der
stufe 40 grad mit wasser und dann
trocknet der teig nicht aus und geht
natürlich viel schneller auf ich hab
dann sind wir zu dir gott dafür
verstehen dass plötzlich jeder mac
manchmal gucke auf jeden fall zeit ist
abgelaufen
es sieht so faktisch punkten liegt es
aufgegangen ist und das backen weht hier
eine halbe stunde bei 200 grad
und dann stellen wir unter auf 170 und
dann noch zehn minuten dann ist das brot
fertig perfekt aufs brot muss man etwa
fünf minuten
wir können schon mal als ich liebe brot
mit butter einfach ganz frischer butter
hat jetzt selber
ich habe hier seine drin die habe ich so
auf raumtemperatur gebracht und jetzt
hat man einfach so ein verschluss glas
und schüttelt ein ganz kleines brot
fertig ist ja das machen wir jetzt so
manche machen sie mit dem hand hörer
aber es doch jetzt echt einfach möchtest
du mir schwalbe arbeitet ja wir wissen
halt der stärkere part von uns beiden
mal gucken ob sich das auf die brutto
auch so überträgt teilweise groß siehst
du da lernt man immer ganz schön viele
ja ich immer früher mit meinen
grundschülern gemacht und die wusste man
wenn man butter lassen
ich wusste mir sie zu schlagen der mauer
auf youtube ist ja auch so ne youtube
war früher also als ich youtube
kennengelernt habe war das so eine reine
musik und videoplattform ich habe halten
sie gehört dann kamen so die tutorials
keine ahnung wie kann ich zum ersten mal
ich habe gesehen wie meine augenbrauen
selber zucht so war das start und dann
dachte ich okay machen wir mal ein
rezept tutorials aber ihr habt euch ja
schon verwandelt also ist keine reine
videoplattform was sind bei euch so wird
die nächsten großen projekte ja ich habe
mal kurz auf die brust zu schlagen ist
jetzt gleich schwierig naja zum einen
sind wir immer nur eine video plattform
und ist nur noch das kern unseres
geschäftes und deswegen arbeiten ja auch
so viele quellen mit uns zusammen aber
es hat sich viel
der creator seite getan sondern auch
sagen es hat angefangen mit erzähl ich
lass uns videos hochladen und mit der
welt teilen hinzu es geht vielmehr um
auch wirklich fanbase aufzubauen mit den
leuten in verbindung zu treten mit den
leuten zu kommunizieren ist der eine
wesentliche aspekt das zweite ist
natürlich auch dass vieles aus
wirtschaftlichen interesse tun um
einfach ein geschäft aufmachen wollen
was jetzt völlig legitim ist aber auch
spannend ist ja und unser job das ist
immer zum für viele berufe entwickelt
hat es hat sich jetzt haben sie sich
sehr sehr viele beruf entwickelt das hat
sehr viel beschäftigung gegeben viele
viele jobs sind dadurch entstanden
ich bin wirklich interessieren wieviele
jobs einig in deutschland durch youtube
entstanden wahrscheinlich etwas wirklich
herausfinden wenn allein bei uns hier
ist jetzt keinen treffer landen aber die
sind jetzt wissen mittlerweile 45 45
leute 15 hier beim schnitt auch in den
grafiken der rest ist anders im
onlineshop und angefangen hat es mit dem
youtube-video so gut naja und und unser
job ist es halt creator dabei zur
creator und partner musiker dabei zu
unterstützen
praktische ihre ziele zu erreichen auf
der einen seite haben wir viel gemacht
hat investieren insbesondere mehr in dem
bereich haben jetzt community und
kommunikation
was haben wir gelernt wir haben wir
prämiert gelaunched ist ein feature
welches dir erlaubt eine videopremiere
so zu feiern praktisch wie im livestream
wohl zeigen demand pds ein tolles
feature mit der möglichkeit dabei zu
chatten und in verbindung mit einem
fenster treten bis ziemlich gut und das
ist machen wir wenn wir die harry potter
tor zu machen
da hat man so viel ich schon drauf dann
wird sich dieses schädlich ein bisschen
die butter und stories ist ein anderes
thema praktisch während premier sagte
heyenn zeit ist in stores sind kurze
ganz einfach produzierbar videos die du
praktisch frei machen kannst sie aber
auch die lehrer glauben dass ohne große
produktionszeit direkten kontakt mit den
fans zu treten das mit der höheren
frequenz zu tun ganz spannend wir haben
vor einiger zeit den krieg getippt
überarbeiten ist der funktionierte auch
sehr gut
und diese ganzen kommunikationstools das
ist ein bereich in dem wir sehr stark
investieren damit auch noch einiges
kommen dadurch entspannt auf der
business seite haben wir versuchen wir
die die basis praktisch zur breit zu
verbreitern aus dem sich creator wie
finanzen
wir befinden uns weiterhin der kern
unseres geschäftes im system die sehr
viel rein machen wir sehr viele
fortschritte in den bereichen versuchen
halt beim geschäft euch die möglichkeit
geben zu diversifizieren
deutsch ist ein thema ich die
möglichkeit unter dem video praktisch
sind dass buttons wo du eigene
merchandising artikel verkaufen kannst
und das spannende ist viel macht es
natürlich selber macht doch sowieso
selber werde den eigenen shop aber nicht
jeder kann das wie gesagt bestellen
infrastruktur zur verfügung das über
youtube auch abzubilden spannendes thema
membership was entspannendes thema wo du
gegen ein kleines gegen ein kleines
entgelt praktisch mitglied eines kanal
werden kannst und praktisch gut ist
bekommt ja das können jogis sein das
können button sein das kann aber nicht
im park sein also dinge die die jeden
kanal gibt exklusive videos premieren
vouchers usw gibt ja auch schon in
deutschland
das gibt es in deutschland ganz genau
und dann haben wir super chat das ist
ein tool welches bei praktisch
vielleicht programm funktioniert wo wir
die möglichkeit haben fans die
möglichkeit haben sich eine besondere
platzierung im live-chat 2000 dann wird
es eine vorgezogene hervorgehoben dass
genau das auch länger dann zu sehen sein
die entspannteste und 65 prozent der
teilnehmenden kanäle haben ihre live
stream rewe news verdoppelt ich habe
eine gute nachricht für dich ja aber ich
gut geschüttelt hat aber noch linsen so
normalerweise würde ich dir jetzt noch
in eiswasser kneten ja dann drückst du
nämlich nochmal so die buttermilch im
alter daraus aber wir lassen die so kuck
mal sieht fantastisch aus
ja so einfach
alles in butter
[Musik]
jetzt wo wir unser brot ich bin gespannt
ich muss mal raus das ist ja mal
gelungen
das sieht gut aus ich glaube das brot
ist nur so gut gelungen weil die
backform von innen und von außen
gefüttert was spielst ja das hätte
natürlich das erfassen dies noch
ziemlich heißt wir nehmen es jetzt gar
schon da und soll den fünf minuten
scheinbar das programm jetzt nächstes
super sehr gut mensch mensch kommt
zusammen aber es gegen das aber flott
das war ein ice muster legt dann kann
man noch so der rest flüssigkeit
ausdrücken
das haben erst mal ein bisschen komisch
brutto zu kneten aber rodrigo macht echt
spaß weil mit kids so schneider unser
brot auf jeden fall ist jetzt halt noch
frisch aber ich habe es jetzt den titel
abgehakt und oben aber vor allem das
schöne kruste und pro das übrigens immer
fertig wenn sich wohl anhört wenn man
unten am boden klopft und die seiten
sind so schön weich dann probier mal
traf ich ja mit frischer butter machen
ist immer so ein highlight
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt also habe ich
vorher nicht gemacht ich glaube ich habe
noch nie vorher brot gemacht jetzt total
das probiere ich selbst gemachtes brot
mit selbst gemachter zusagen wie werde
ich rächen
[Musik]
hmm wie schmeckt fantastisch wirklich
wirklich gut
doch leicht war
hmm man schmeckt die holzformen bisschen
soll man ja roma vom holz trinkt echt
ins klo nein und wenn ihr keine oliven
mit könnt ihr zum beispiel auch tomaten
getrocknete oder cross zwiebeln trotzdem
echt drauf ich habe ja was ich noch
franke ich habe letztes jahr eine
letzten jahre ist meine eigene stiftung
gegründet
und da engagieren wir uns für soziale
projekte ich gucke dass schulen in der
küche ausgestattet werden oder schon mal
in kindergärten es geht uns um eine
bereich bildung erziehung ernährung
macht jeder auf wasser so engagiert ihr
euch als youtube als kugel sozial
irgendwo ja das ist eigentlich immer
jährlich ist praktisch die genetik
unserer plattform youtube ist eine
plattform die sowohl die mission hat
leuten die stimme zu geben und den
nutzern die welt zu zeigen
von daher eine stimme
früher war es als er schwer einfach nur
meine stimme hat so etwas sagen wollte
wirklich eine öffentlichkeit zu filmen
und gab hat geschlossene systeme und
kamele und die debatte nötig gemacht
mit leuten zu reden und seine botschaft
rauszubringen
das kann er in der botschaft sein und
das kann aber auch eine botschaft sein
wo es um gesellschaftliche themen geht
und wo es um veränderung gegner ist das
praktisch verankert in unserer plattform
wir haben intern reden wir sogar von
grin von vier freiheiten die wir unsere
plattformen also denen wir unsere
plattform unterordnen
zum einen ist es die die
meinungsfreiheit ich glaube dass es ganz
wichtig ist dass jeder seine meinung
sagen darf und sie unterstützen das
natürlich auch entsprechend für vielfalt
wir haben keine redakteure die bei uns
inhalte kontrollieren haben die
community pipelines aber ansonsten auch
wenn die meinung vielleicht nicht
besonders populär ist gehen wir eine
plattform die informationsfreiheit da
geht es um zugang von informationen
youtube ist ein bildungsmedium auch sie
selber lehrerin von einem freien zugang
zu informationen ist grundvoraussetzung
für für bildung da ist die freiheit der
zugehörigkeit glauben fest daran dass
wenn man eine gruppe ist sich mit leuten
zusammen gut kann man mehr erreichen
bei uns geht es darum dass wir diese
bildung von groß
für den kreis gemeinschaften ermöglichen
deswegen diese ganzen community tools
und dass wir auch den übergang von einer
gruppe zu anderen einfach gestalten so
können wir den bau und sondern praktisch
wenn darunter neben ja und das letzte
ist chance freiheit als unternehmerin
jeder soll die chance haben erfolgreich
zu werden und effekten soll das publikum
entscheiden was funktioniert und nicht
die all die plattform oder jemand
anderes und wir haben auch sie haben
eigene programme mit denen wir solche
greater unterstützen der von der sgg
raiders change ganz tolles programm wo
wir creator die ein gesellschaftliches
anliegen haben helfen ihr
gesamtgesellschaftliches anliegen der
breiten masse zugänglich zu machen den
politischen bühne zu geben sie zu
fördern als 218 hatten wir viele
deutsche lied über die mitgemacht haben
der täter waren das thema zu lösen war
das ein lette war dabei war das und
mexikos die stadt entweder für toleranz
offenheit für talentförderung und all
diese dinge also das ist ein sehr
wichtiges thema im feature an dem wir
arbeiten was wir noch nicht haben aber
hoffentlich bald schon werden ist eine
geringe funktion die es erlaubt einen
youtube auch für spendenaufruf zwecke
einzusetzen und zwar direkt auf der
plattform von facebook zu betreiben was
für dich sicherlich auch selbst den
aufruf haben auch schon viele gemacht
habe ist natürlich immer ziemlich
aufwendig mit konto anlegen
bankverbindung und so weiter und dann
kann das praktisch direkt auf der
plattform die die details die aber dass
im prinzip die die idee dahinter dass
wir diesen spendenmöglichkeit
vereinfachen auf der plattform und
direkt auf die plattform ohne super das
finde ich wirklich so kommt ja darauf
ein brot das wort ist echt gut
ich finde wir sollten öfter zusammen
backen brot kuchen
ich finde rhabarberkuchen gut wenn er
gut ist kann man schnell dass auch er
damit streife mit streusel muss man
können
sehr sehr cool so gerne wie form und
fettet ihr von außen verfolgen
gerade weil man aber gucken ist extrem
perfekt durch glaubt man echt coole
fragen beantwortet medien gehen dank
dafür
also jetzt habe ich zumindest ein
bisschen besseren blick hinter die
kulissen wie das ganze bei euch abläuft
und ich freue mich auf das was in
zukunft kommt vor allem auf die neuen
tools und du nimmst jetzt die backform
it und das rezept und kannst du deine
kinder unter der vater will auf jeden
fall ist weiß ich weil wir wollen wir
mal vielen dank für deine
gastfreundschaft vielen dank für eure
menge gelernt dass eine freut es mich
dass du deine fragen das programm passt
oder das gefühl dass sie beantwortet
bekommen zu haben
und ich weiß wie man eine backform backt
beziehungsweise macht
vielen dank und das rezept gibt weber
zum nachlesen auf sallys - blog.de
da findet ihr alle mengenangaben ich
mache gern noch weitere boote rezepte
und adresse wird bestätigen können ganz
wichtig ist vor allem von außen
sein geheimnis sagen das reicht die form
zurück von ihnen zu finden wo er gewusst
[Musik]